hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar label three differently how 3dif
validated antibodies provide clear
signals from clear tissues and large
scale 3d imaging i am antonina salcido
of labrutz and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltoni biotek to learn more
please visit
multnebiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you may
have during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
this webinar is also educational and
thus offers free continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
marcus habish global product manager at
miltoni biotech
marcus you may now begin your
presentation
thank you and thanks to all the webinar
attendees for joining today's webinar my
name is marcus harbich and i'm global
product manager for imaging reagents
here at miltoni biotech
and i would like to take you today on a
tour through the basics of tissue
clearing and immunostaining of large
samples
and presents the workflow that miltani
developed to
easily obtain three-dimensional data of
your samples such as you can see here in
this visual showing a human brain
organoid
so during today's presentation i would
like to touch on the question why to
perform 3d imaging of large samples at
all
and present you the general workflow for
large-scale 3d immunofluorescence
also i will talk about the challenges
that are associated with 3dif labeling
and would like to conclude on
what recombinant antibodies are and how
recombinant antibodies that were
validated for this application are
beneficial for your workflow
and i would like to start out with the
way we see biology today for almost an
entire century
and this is two-dimensional microscopy
of thin sections
and in this schematic you can see a
representation of a sample that has been
sectioned and you would observe blood
vessels here and you would see a
punctate structure
and i think it's obvious that this has
nothing to do with the
actual
nature of blood vessels in three
dimensions
which are
elongated structures that merge and that
branch
and to obtain such an image
the thing that researchers do is either
imagining from 2d sections and data how
a three-dimensional structure would look
like
or
stacking individual pictures
to compute a three-dimensional data set
what i showed you in a schematic before
is here depicted as real data sets
so you can see here a
mouse brain section that has been
stained for cd31 which is an endothelial
marker
with which you can stain for blood
vessels
and this is now the emerging picture you
can see the dotted structures you can
appreciate also some elongated
structures but again this has little to
do with the actual three-dimensional
image that you could obtain with this
new workflow called 3d
immunofluorescence
the real image how the blood vessels of
a mouse brain would look like as you can
appreciate here in this video where you
can see larger blood vessels
which branch down to very fine
structures within deep inside the mouse
brain
additionally there is another aspect
besides just seeing
the biology in three-dimensional how it
really is
the current workflow the standard
two-dimensional workflow that is called
here this uses the sample
and by sectioning and imaging you of
course distort your sample
and with the 3dif workflow this is
avoided because you perform tissue
clearing and you image the entire sample
so when you would try to image and stack
the individual sections together you
would get a very distorted image you
would introduce tissue sectioning
artifacts and also not 100 of the entire
tissue is usually
obtained for analysis so you lose some
of the valuable tissue
which is not the case for the 3dif
workflow where you can analyze the
sample as a whole
so in total the sectioning causes loss
and distortion of the tissue
ultimately leading to incomplete data
which also
includes a hidden miss of rare events
whereas with 3dif visualizing structures
in the 3d spatial context you obtain
truly comprehensive data and there is no
chance of a hit and miss event
did the risk of hit and miss has a very
high relevance is shown in this example
here from merchant colleagues published
last year
as an example from melanoma diagnostics
where usually
a sentinel lymph node which is in
proximity of the melanoma
after a treatment is excised during
operation chemically fixed and then used
for paraffin embedding and preparation
of tissue sections for h e and
immunohistochemistry staining and this
is performed according a fixed grid of
sectioning
and what you can see here is the entire
samples and the lines indicate the
distances of the sections
and you can easily imagine that when
melanoma cells in the lymph node are
located here in between the lines they
would be missed from analysis and a
wrong diagnostics could occur
and as a solution
the author suggested here the workflow
of 3d immunofluorescence which is also
referred to as hormone staining of clear
tissues where the entire samples after
the operation can be processed and
analyzed
in three dimensions
as you can see here after staining for
important markers
so after understanding the relevance of
this large-scale 3dif workflow let's
have a look at the individual steps
it basically comprises three main steps
the first one is labeling of structures
of interest
and for this you can use different
approaches and chemicals
within this talk i will focus on
labeling using antibodies so
immunostaining approaches
the second step is tissue clearing and i
will explain in detail what this is
generally it's a process that renders
tissue transparent
which is a prerequisite for step three
which is
the imaging
volumetric imaging of large samples to
obtain 3d data
here at milton biotech we developed a
workflow
that allows now
imaging of a broad range of tissue sizes
which is depicted here
which spans from small 3d
samples such as tumor spheroids or brain
organoids stained with different
relevant markers
up to tumors several millimeters in size
derived from human or mouse origin
but also entire mouse tissues
such as depicted here where we were able
to
stain clear and image
lymph nodes lung and mouse brain
hemispheres
so very large samples that would
normally not be able to image without
this very special large-scale 3dif
workflow
and for this we at military biotech
developed solutions for the individual
steps of the workflow
the first the labeling step
for this we developed an antibody
portfolio specifically validated
for three-dimensional immunofluorescence
those are recombinant antibodies
that are conjugated to fluorochromes and
specifically tested for this application
the second step the tissue clearing step
we cover with the max clearing kit
this is a tissue clearing kit providing
fast and non-toxic
tissue clearing and also
we provide
protocols for standard samples such as
mouse brain tumor and cerebral organoids
which covers the different aspects of
the entire workflow during sample
preparation
covering the clearing steps but also the
immunolabeling steps
for the third
workflow step the imaging
we do have the ultra microscope place
this is a fully automated light sheet
microscope for volumetric imaging of
large samples
and also as a reagent we provide the max
imaging solution
which
offers a refractive index matched
imaging of large samples that have been
stained and cleared using the military
products here
so during this talk i would like to
tell you about the basics and principles
of the individual steps
and also touch on the challenges
and to better understand this i would
like to approach this
from the back and start out with imaging
then going over tissue clearing and
finalizing on the labeling aspect
also i will focus within this talk on
the sample preparation aspect so i will
be relatively short on the volumetric
imaging aspect
so let's focus on
imaging first a brief
outlook
let's have a look at the different
imaging modalities that exist to cover
the vast range
of imaging biological systems
so what you can appreciate is that each
modality focuses on a quite narrow range
of
sample size and scale
and for example often used or confocal
microscopy or two-photon microscopy
research to identify several hundred
nanometer structures up to cells and
tissues
but
so far there has not been one imaging
modality that can now bridge the gap of
imaging cells up to entire rodent organs
or whole animals but this is now
the
technology
that came with light sheet microscopy
and tissue clearing and in combination
these two
technologies they really unlock the huge
potential to analyze now biological
systems across scales
to understand lightsheet microscopy
let's first have a look at confocal
points getting microscopy
in this standard method the excitation
happens on the same axis as the emission
light is collected
it is collected by a pmt where a pinhole
in front of blocks out of focus light to
obtain the confocal image
and
with this method what you do is you
excite the entire tissue above and below
the focal plane
so in general point scanning confocal
microscopy brings the challenges of
scattering that is occurring in large
samples so it's not easy to image deep
inside
larger samples and also the scanning
speed is relatively slow because you
scan point by point
what is shown here on this figure is the
imaging depth that can be acquired using
confocal microscopy on the left hand
side using a non-cleared mouse brain
where you can see that you can only
image until 75 microns in depth
and in comparison tissue clearing
unlocks now here
a lot more
planes to be imaged within the tissue so
definitely improving here the image
quality already
but let's have a look at light sheet
fluorescence microscopy how this works
and what are the images that you can
obtain
the main difference here is that you
decouple the excitation and the emission
access
you excite perpendicular to the emission
detection
and you excite exactly one focal plane
at one time of which you can detect the
image
at the same time
also bringing the benefit that you do
not excite structures above and beneath
the sample
basically light sheet fluorescence
microscopy
by decoupling these
axes
you act as a fast virtual microtome
and
in combination with tissue clearing now
this really unlocks the potential for
large scale imaging
it is also a lot faster because you can
acquire the image of an entire focal
plane at once
and fast as cmos cameras are used
and you increase the sample size making
light sheet fluorescence microscopy the
go-to technology for a large scale
3d fluorescence microscopy imaging
in this figure now you see the
comparison of the confocal
microscope image with a cleared sample
where we saw okay you can measure deep
inside the tissue but now in comparison
with the light sheet technology using a
clear tissue you're now able to properly
image
the tissue in its entire depth at high
quality
the state the
lychee microscope developed at multani
biotech is the ultra microscope blaze
and this is a new light sheet instrument
that comes with three
main benefits
which is that you're now able to
measure largest or multiple samples at
once with a
large imaging cuvette
and also with a sample holder allowing
application of different samples
also it is fully automated
with magnification changes and objective
changes and also a fully automated
loading and opening of the device
and also it is equipped with cutting
edge optics that are compatible with all
clearing media allowing them staggering
image data from low resolution up to 30x
high resolution images
unfortunately i do not have the time to
go into detail on the ultra microscope
place within this webinar but i would
like to refer you to the miltoni website
where we have included several webinars
specifically in focusing on this topic
so with this let's have a look at the
second step of the workflow
called tissue clearing
so to understand what tissue clearing is
one has to have a look at why tissues
are opaque so non-transparent and this
is because incident light faces
different effects such as reflection
refraction scattering and absorption and
this is mainly because large samples
they contain of different
molecules that bring along different
refractive indices
and tissue clearing aims at unifying the
refractive index between
surrounding medium and the sample
allowing then
light to fully traverse through the
sample without facing any of these
effects
to make this a little uh visual what
this means is
i brought you here this excerpt from
this youtube video which nicely shows
how you can
render
object transparent by filling it with a
medium of the same refractive index and
you can see here these bubbles
they fully disappear when water is added
which has now the same refractive index
so they become transparent and that this
is also possible with
tissues you can see here in this little
video
which is showing an adult mouse brain
hemisphere
in a time-lapse video
during the tissue clearing step so
within six hours you've rendered this
tissue transparent allowing then proper
volumetric imaging using light sheet
microscopy
so by now many different tissue clearing
protocols have been published
and all of them they fall mainly in
three individual
classes of tissue clearing protocols
the first one is hydrophobic clearing
where the final step the ri matching
happens in an organic solvent
the second is referred to as hydrophilic
clearing and cubic is a well-known
representative of those where the iri
matching happens and hyper hydration
and finally the hydrogel-based clearing
methods such as clarity they're based on
embedding of the sample and the
synthetic gel which allows them
relatively hard harsh steps for
deliberation and staining it finally ri
matching
these different classes of protocols
they
focus on different applications and come
with different pros and cons
they
differ in terms of individual steps and
sequence and also chemicals
and
users have to optimize their
protocol
in their own lab for their own approach
and since there are many different
applications also
many different clearing protocols have
been developed so far falling into three
categories and this is just an overview
of a few of those of the main tissue
clearing protocols and how they emerged
from the individual
basic clearing protocols
so the very first one was the
schpalterholz technique and from this
many of the organic clearing protocols
such as babb clearing and the disco
protocols emerged
and i will not go into detail now
explaining the pros and cons of the
different
tissue clearing protocols but would like
to refer you to this very nice review by
mobile and colleagues from this year
where they have a nice introduction into
disco clearing and also give a nice
overview of the individual tissue
clearing protocols
the main point here is that
by now more than 60
published clearing protocols are
available and it is actually very hard
to find the suited protocol for your
application
so with this vast diversity of different
protocols being out there it is very
intransparent and hard for users to get
started with the topic of tissue
clearing for their application
and this is also something that you see
upcoming now
is support in the literature with
different review articles focusing on
tissue clearing and different areas of
tumor biology
developmental biology or neuroscience
and also in nice guidebooks to get
people starting for
specific tissue clearing methods
so in total it is very cumbersome for
beginners to get started and to set this
method up in your lab
so this is exactly something that
miltoni biotech wanted to take up here
with this in transparency and to develop
a tissue clearing method and protocol
that is straightforward and takes the
users by the hand to get really started
and for this the hydrophobic clearing
was used as a basis with the benefits of
high speed and high quality
and focusing on circumventing the
negative aspects that this method brings
along such as tissue shrinkage and the
use of severely toxic substances
and by this
the max clearing kit was developed as an
easy to use hydrophobic tissue clearing
approach
that is absolutely non-toxic
and brings minimal shrinkage of the
tissue
the workflow for this tissue clearing
protocol looks the following so
samples are fixed and this is then
dependent on the sample size whether you
would perform perfusion or incubation in
a fixative
then permeabilization
is performed
following a immunostaining step labeling
structures of interest
and for
our eye matching using organic
substances a dehydration in ethanol is
performed until you are then matching
the refractive index and clearing the
tissue for 3d imaging
and for this the kit consists of a
dedicated permeabilization solution
antibody staining solution and a
clearing solution
bringing together here the different
components of the kit but also the max
imaging solution as i mentioned earlier
provides here then the refractive index
matched imaging solution
so as i mentioned this clearing kit
provides simple and non-toxic tissue
clearing
as you can see here this is relatively
fast so with only a six hour step you're
able to fully clear
brain tissue but also
tumor tissue this is shown here with the
human ovarian carcinoma sample
making it
in total highly efficient and robust
tissue clearing
where you don't have to take special
precautions as compared to other organic
clearing protocols that have toxic
substances so here this is a non-toxic
tissue clearing method
that is specifically optimized for hole
mount immunostaining which it can be a
really tricky part which i will focus on
later
and in addition to make it as easy as
possible we developed easy to follow
protocols for different standard tissues
that we are also going to expand in the
future
to give you a quick overview on the
protocols that we developed so far
for mouse brain hemispheres
human primary tumors or patient derived
casino grafts or cerebral organoids
this in total
yields a workflow of 12 days for the
first two sample types or only five days
for the letter sample types this is
basically
due to the different tissue sizes
and if you know the total duration of
other clearing protocols taking three to
four weeks this is a very fast organic
tissue clearing protocol that we provide
here
this already includes the immunostaining
step which is here the longest step
coming with eight days of incubation
with antibody
it is not limited to the standard
protocols that we provide but we have
observed a good compatibility with a
broad range of organs whether it's mouse
lung intestine lymph node
and whatsoever so we see very good
compatibility with different kinds of
tissues
so after we've seen what tissue clearing
is and the miltonia biotech solution to
that let's have a look at the first step
of the 3dif workflow labeling
to understand why it is important to
provide a dedicated solution let's have
a look at the challenges
and usually in two-dimensional
immunofluorescence or
immunohistochemistry
thin
sections are used for immunostaining
typically an ffpe section is 5 micron
thickness ranging up to 20 microns for
frozen sections
and now when going here to the
step of
trying to stain an entire
organ you are now
working with samples that are about 125
times thicker
and this is here put in scale what this
would mean when you try now in
comparison to a thin section label an
entire mouse brain so you can imagine
that it is not straightforward and it
comes with
specific effects when trying to label
such big samples using antibodies
and these antibodies they have also to
stay in the center of the tissue of
course
and they also have to survive the tissue
clearing step
in total
the users report
different challenges and this is nicely
summarized also again in this review i
mentioned before
i picked here three of very high
importance
challenges that they face it is first
the complexity of the entire procedure
and especially of immunolabeling steps
also the time required for the procedure
represents a challenge and finally the
background signals and also
reproducibility
are critical in this workflow making
overall the method and immunolabeling of
large samples prohibitively cumbersome
to set up in their own labs
let's have a look at the different
factors affecting the 3dif labeling and
this is actually quite a long list of
the different parameters that you have
to keep in mind when setting up an 3dif
labeling protocol
the first and most important is which
antibody are you using for 3dif and this
has to be determined empirically
many antibodies do not work for this
approach
and you also have to take into account
do you want to use a monoclonal or a
polyclonal antibody polyclonal giving
higher signal intensity because several
epitopes are targeted of one
target protein but at cost of
specificity and also what was the
immunogen that was used for raising the
antibody against so these are reasons
why
several antibodies can or cannot work in
this application
also epitope accessibility and fixation
is an important topic so you must avoid
over fixation of the tissue of interest
to ensure proper binding of antibodies
to the target
also the tissue clearing protocol is an
important factor so
when
setting up an immunolabeling protocol
first decide on a tissue clearing
protocol that you want to find one
suited anybody against testing than
different antibodies for one tissue
clearing protocol due to the different
steps and chemicals used across the
different protocols
this will influence the
performance of immunolabeling
also direct versus indirect labeling
makes a difference so con using
conjugated primary antibodies versus
pure primaries and the secondary
antibody
and this has effect on the protocol
duration but can also affect the tissue
penetration
of the antibody
then classically antibody concentration
and incubation time have a effect of the
3dif labeling
and it is generally recommended to start
out with small
samples to test an antibody for example
thick sections before going to the
entire organ to validate an antibody and
then only for the final experiment go
into the large sample
and finally
antibody background binding
and fluorochrome choice are factors
affecting 3dif labeling both of which
topics which i also will take up later
during this talk and fluorochrome choice
it is important to use small and bright
fluorochromes to allow proper tissue
penetration
and with this i would like to present
you the
recently launched antibody portfolio for
3dif by miltoni biotek
and in brief they come with the three
features being validated for this
specific application
they are conjugated to fluorochromes
and they are recombinantly engineered
and what this means i would like to show
you in the next slide
i will focus first on these two points
and then later touch on recombinant
antibodies and why this is important
so when getting started with an
immunolabeling protocol for larger
samples often what is observed by users
is
that antibodies stick to the surface of
larger samples and this here is a
cerebral organoid
has been stained with an antibody not
optimized for concentration and not
checked for compatibility
generally we have user information that
only one out of six antibodies generally
work for clear tissue imaging
making the screening progress
process very expensive
so this is something that
we did in advance we validated our
antibody portfolio
for compatibility with the protocol
itself
using the max clearing kit and our
standard protocols so we checked
on large samples for tissue penetration
signal to background ratios and also
provide a recommended dilution to make
the titration in your application a
little easier
also what we do is we use a different
range of standard samples where we check
for proper antibody diffusion through
fixed samples
and
as examples i show you here a brain
organoid a cerebral organoid of human
origin ips c derived
and you can see here a triple staining
of beta-3 tubulin for neuronal cells
ki-67 for proliferation and stocks too
for neuroprogenitor cells
going to larger sizes such as
entire primary human tumors and here you
can see an ovarian carcinoma that has
been stained with our cytokeratin
antibody in gray you see the
autofluorescence of the tissue
and the largest
example that we use in standard
validation
are mouse brain hemispheres and here you
can see as an example of a cd31 staining
where you can appreciate very nice
staining of the center of the tissue
indicating a proper antibody diffusion
and penetration throughout the entire
sample
i mentioned that our antibodies are
fluorochrome conjugated
and
usually using an indirect immune
staining approach using the protocol
what you can see is that for an example
of a mouse brain hemisphere you're
finished after 20 days of
protocol
and one major bulk of this time comes
from the secondary antibody incubation
and this is something that you can can
cut down by half almost
and
by using primary antibodies that are
conjugated to fluorochromes allowing you
in this example to analyze the brain
data eight days earlier which makes a
huge difference
another interesting effect that we
observed was that
it also has an influence on the tissue
penetration
whether you use primary conjugated or
secondary antibody approach
and what you can see here is a mouse
brain hemisphere
and this is an idisco plus
protocol that has been used
and it has been incubated with the
neurofilament antibody
conjugated to viral rs667
and you can appreciate a proper staining
deep within the tissue
and what has been performed in addition
is a secondary antibody conjugate with a
different fluorochromes alexa 555
has been used to detect the primary
antibody
and what you can appreciate here is that
the secondary did not manage to
penetrate
through the entirety of the tissue and
you see here this black space
indicating that not
the sample had not been stained
harmoniously as you can also see here in
this merge image
indicating that
using the primary antibody approach
using primary conjugated is also
beneficial for tissue penetration
so finally i would like to focus on the
aspect of providing recombinantly
engineered antibody
this fact came up with the
reproducibility crisis about six years
ago
where antibodies were
detected as
one main cause for irreproducible
results in research
so in this figure from plus biology you
can see that about 30 billion us dollars
were estimated
to be associated with irreproducible
results and that one reason for this
is biological reagents and reference
materials
and as a follow-up
here in the survey it was asked
which product groups caused these issues
with reproducibility
and here antibodies were at position
number two causing
major irreproducible results
so as an outcome the consensus of the
research community was that recombinant
monoclonal antibodies are the way out of
the irreproducibility crisis based on
antibodies
and this is because recombinant
antibodies are defined in their dna
sequence
and are transduced into a defined
expression system thereby yielding
high load to lot consistent products
which definitely influences
reproducibility
very positively and this is in
comparison to
the polyclonal antibody technology where
a serum of immunized animals is used
where i think many customers reported
high lots a lot of variations and bad
reproducibility
and also in comparison to monoclonal
antibodies derived from hybrid doma
technology
where
which is definitely better for
reproducibility purposes but still
coming from the basis of technology or
fusing b cells with myeloma cells
the final product contains contaminating
light chains derived from the myeloma
cells
leading to unproductive antibodies in
the lots and this can be different
across different lots
thereby
putting here recombinant monoclonal
antibodies as
the gold method to
overcome the
reproducibility crisis
to convince you that this is actually
the case that monoclonal antibodies can
be contaminated with myeloma
light chains this experiment was used
where the antibody of a mouse monoclonal
hybridoma was sent to maaspec in
comparison to a recombinant ray affinity
antibody to detect the light chains
and the emerging picture was that for
mouse monoclonal antibody you would
detect two different peaks one
only being for the productive light
chain and the other peak resembles the
contaminating light chain and in this
example it is even the case that the
contaminating light chain represents the
majority of the
light chain within the tube whereas this
is not the case for reaffinity
antibodies where you see
defined
light chain signals
we launched antibody portfolio for 3dif
with any biotech now transfers the
expertise of a decade of recombinant
antibody engineering and production to
the 3dif
protocol and method
and thereby providing a lot a lot
consistent antibodies for this
application that are selected for the
highest specificity
and in addition we're also
engineered to
yield no background signal
usually antibodies they contain an fc
receptor binding region in their
backbone
and this has been genetically engineered
with introducing mutations to abolish
this background binding to immune cells
that would be present within your sample
and finally we used small and bright
fluorochromes of the viodi family
for this antibody portfolio to provide
optimal tissue penetration and signal to
background ratios
these biodyes they are a special class
of fluorochromes that are small organic
dyes
and by the small size they are
beneficial for a good tissue penetration
they are bright to obtain high signal to
background ratios also within large
samples
and they are particularly photostable
providing constant signals during the
imaging of the large sample
and with this portfolio release
we have now two different fluorochromes
available for the 3dif antibodies
and they basically correspond to
spectrally to the alexa floor 488
and via rs667 corresponds to alexa fluid
647
thereby providing very good
compatibility when you're already using
these kind of fluorochromes
in terms of laser excitation and the
emission filters
to transfer
these fluorochromes also into your
experiments
a little important side note here so the
nomenclature of our via dyes are
according to the excitation laser here
either blue or red
and the emission wavelength
515 here for the alexa 488 correspondent
which you can see here this is the
emission max while the excitation max is
488 and likewise for via rs667
and in terms of photo stability this is
a quick
graphic that i want to show here this is
a photo degradation essay
where we used either the green
fluorochrome bio b515 against alexa 488
or fitzy where you can see superior
photo stability for vio b515
or also the same here for via rs667
against alexa floor 647 or cy5 where you
can appreciate
a lot superior photo stability for the
valve dies
with the first release of our antibodies
for 3d if we are now able to support
detection of mouse blood vessels or
immune cells using cd4 or cd45
antibodies
but also the cross-reactive ki-67
antibody to detect proliferation in
human or mouth cells
but also if you're analyzing human cells
to detect for example infiltrating
immune cells t cells or leukocytes in
general this is possible and also
staining the tumor
cells of epithelial origin for example
using cytokeratin or apcam antibodies
also for organoid development we do have
antibodies of relevance
videos here during my presentation but i
will focus here on this data set using a
human ovarian carcinoma sample that has
been stained for leukocytes using cd45
rs667 antibody where you can see a nice
overview of the leukocytes in this
cancer sample
and this has been cleared with the max
clearing kit and imaged with the ultra
microscope blaze so you can appreciate
here also the imaging across the
different scales seeing the overview but
also zooming in
for
the details of the sample here
and as another example here is a 3dif
staining of a human cerebral or brain
organoid
here you see neuronal cells stained with
beta tubulin 3 antibody
which
is then correlated with ki-67
staining showing proliferating cells and
here sucks too to sustain neural
progenic cells
also this sample has been
cleared using the max clearing kit and
imaged using an ultra microscope to
light sheet instrument
this brings me to the end of my talk
which i would like to summarize with the
following three aspects
i showed you that we recently launched
antibody specifically validated for 3dif
to give you good confidence and reagents
to get your 3dif experiments started
these are of recombinant nature and
therefore
are of highest quality leading to
reproducible 3dif data
and to make it as easy as possible
multani biotech provides a simple and
non-toxic workflow for large-scale 3d
imaging
also providing
nice simple and easy to follow protocols
and with this i would like to thank you
very much for joining today's webinar
the choice is now up to you
and if you have questions that you would
like to ask me i'm looking forward to
answer them
in the q and a session now
thanks a lot
thank you marcus for your informative
presentation we'll now start the live q
a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for now let's get
started
our first question
is do your antibodies work on organoids
and material fixed with four percent pfa
thanks a lot yeah very good question
so we do provide a protocol for cerebral
organoids for example and in this case
they were not grown in metro gel
but there were
also pfa fixed using four percent pfa
then permeable eyes used for
immuno labeling and afterwards an
agarose embedding takes place for then
dehydration and refractive index
matching
and with the
material grown organoids we have not
tested this yet
but i could imagine if the antibody
labeling is proper
still with the metrogel that
this works out as well as we see good
compatibility of the agarose during
dehydration and refractive index
matching
but at the moment this is only
theoretically um judging this and one
would have to test this
but it would be really interesting to
see if you make the
observations what the outcome would be
thank you
our next question have you found that
labeling before clearing works better
than clearing first i'm curious why you
chose that order
yes great point um so we chose that
order because our clearing method is
based on organic tissue clearing this
means that
in the end the refractive index matching
happens with an organic agent and for
this you need to dehydrate your samples
and the antibody labeling needs to
happen in aqueous solution so this is
why we first permeabilize the samples
perform the antibody labeling and only
then
subject the sample to dehydration
and refractive index matching using the
organic clearing agent
you could in principle also first do a
dehydration maybe optimizing then the
permeabilization but we saw that our
permeabilization solution
is um
highly efficient and that you would not
need to
go through that workflow so you can make
it really straightforward work first in
the aqueous environment and then go on
to the organic phase
i know that the aqueous tissue clearing
methods they do have a clearing step
before labeling and making sure that the
um all the liplets are removed and the
sample is properly
permeabilized before immuno labeling but
due to the nature of the organic tissue
clearing protocol we chose
that sequence and see very good effects
and stainings
thanks
we have some great questions coming in
and the next one does the max clearing
kit support preservation of an
indigenously expressed fluorescent
proteins
such as
gfp yes very good question
so we have performed the experiments and
when using ph adjusted ethanol for
dehydration we see that the gfp and rfp
signals were nicely preserved
it is in the end dependent on the
expression strength of the promoter that
you would use for
the fluorescent protein expression
in general using organic clearing
protocols you will observe a certain
loss of the fluorescence but you can
adapt the protocol to preserve this
fluorescence but however if you're using
dim expression of for example gfp it is
generally recommended to boost the gfp
signal using
antibodies that are targeted against the
fluorescent protein
for a proper readout and imaging
with great signals in 3d yeah so it is
possible but it is a matter of the
expression string
perfect thank you
are your antibodies only suited for
clear tissue imaging or also for
standard fluorescence microscopy using
wired feel of confocal systems
yeah great question
we promoted here especially for the 3d
if workflow of course but
there is no reason why these antibodies
should not work for thin section
labeling using standard
immunofluorescence or ifc workflows also
using
adherent or suspension cells so
absolutely yes should be compatible
perfect thank you
another question the antibodies are
validated for clear tissue imaging in
combination with the max clearing kit do
you have any experience on other organic
clearing methods
yes so we routinely test and validate
these antibodies in combination with the
max clearing kit
but
which is an organic clearing method but
we also tested the compatibility
with idisco plus
and for the set of antibodies that we
tested we saw very good signals
and it has to be highlighted that
this protocol also used a methanol
pre-treatment step which usually
leads to very poor epitope preservation
and most antibodies are not compatible
but using this protocol this was also
shown in the presentation for example
using the neurofilament
antibody that is
still not released yet but soon we saw
very um good signals and
based on these as a proxy we think that
the organic tissue clearing protocols
are compatible with these antibodies as
well
and i would assume also for aqueous
solutions or cleaning protocols
okay thank you
another question i am working in
neuroscience do you also provide
antibodies to detect most important cell
types in mouth central nervous system
yes
with the first release so in general we
will continuously release further
antibodies for this portfolio
so have a look
regularly on the website which are
released to market in this very first
launch
we focused on immune oncology
specific antibodies
but we will soon also release a set of
neurospecific antibodies
to label
neuronal cells
career cells
and astrocytes oligodendrocytes so the
most relevant
cns cell population
will be able to be detected
with the set of neural antibodies to be
released soon yes
great thank you another question we have
is your clearing agent compatible with
upright microscopes dipping into
objectives in parentheses
yes so
we do have
when presenting the workflow of course
we um focus on large-scale 3d imaging
where light sheet microscopy is
generally the go-to method but confocal
microscopes
are the standard in labs
usually and also
the question to upright microscopy
is related to that if also alternative
microscope setups can be used
and in principle yes so there are also
um 3d printing models for such systems
out there
and also without that with
low n a high working distance objectives
it is possible to also image using
organic clearing solutions deep
inside the tissues it's a little bit
about optimization of the
the method itself but yes that is
possible there are different resources
out there as well um
yeah giving more insights on
how you can do this
and not using light sheet imaging but a
confocal or a wide field setup
definitely this is possible yes
thank you we have time for a couple more
questions
and so another one you showed vob um 515
and vor667
as fluorochromes available in the
antibody portfolio for 3dif will you
focus on these two fluorochromes for
your 3dif antibody portfolio
right yes i showed these two
fluorochromes
because they are now available
to the market
with our 3dif antibody portfolio
and those are the first ones that we
release but those will not be the only
ones so
we will release further colors as well
in different channels
the vaio r667 and this is the red dye
that we have for this antibody portfolio
and this is of greatest importance
because
um you will observe a lot of
autofluorescence and the green channels
so there
they are compatible for smaller samples
such as organoids
when going to large samples such as moss
brine
then a redshifted die is beneficial and
therefore the via rs667
is
very well compatible
and as i said this is the first set more
com colors will come soon as well thank
you
hey another question and we have very
exciting developments for those of us
that are imaging steroid micro tissues
have you observed any penetration limits
related to high levels of antigen in the
sample aka the barrier effect
that is an excellent question
so far when we had analyzed steroids or
organoids
we did not encounter this effect
but when i showed you the
the data on the neurofilament staining
you think the secondary antibody
targeting the primary antibody this
might also have been such a molecular
crowding effect
um which might be based on the
high expression of neurofilament in the
brain
and therefore leading to a limited pore
size when labeling with the primary
antibody in order for the secondary
antibody to be not able anymore to
penetrate through the entire
brain
so in short we've not observed this for
spheroids and organoids but for larger
samples indeed
thank you we have time for just one more
question and the last one where can i
learn more about your 3d if workflow
um
we do have a workflow website and i
think it is no problem to
paste the link here in the chat for
everybody to to have this at hand right
yes
go ahead and do that
great thank you
perfect um thank you so much marcus do
you have any final comments for our
audience
yes i would like to thank all the
webinar attendees for joining today's
webinar
i hope it was informative and hope to
see your data soon using our portfolio
of reagents thank you
thank you so much again marcus for your
time today and your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their all their interesting questions we
had a lot come in questions we do not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with any
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
thank you so much until next time
goodbye